just missed it we had a round of
applause here in the channel 8 phone
bank because the first phone call of the
day came through and this is the first
time we're actually really talking about
it if you have medicare questions these
good folks can answer them so give that
number a call 702-650-1101
to talk more about this we're joined by
danielle jones of select health thanks
for being here first of all danielle
tell us about select health who is
select health select health is
a not-for-profit health plan and our
mission is to help people live the
healthiest lives possible and we are an
integrated health system with
intermountain health care and we offer
medicare advantage plans in idaho nevada
and utah and our goal is to offer
personalized service and high quality
care to all of our members and this
window opened up october 15th and
continues for a little while this is the
time to enroll in medicare or to change
your plan this is the time so the annual
enrollment period runs from october 15
through december 7 and now is the time
that you want to review all of your
options so you want to look at things
like medications it's just a good
reminder every year if you're on a
medicare plan that you want to just
review all of your options your costs
your doctors your prescriptions so this
is the time every year where you really
have that opportunity so when does
someone know they are eligible for
medicare in life
when you're turning 65 so when you're
turning 65 you have about a seven month
window so the month of your birthday and
then three months prior and three months
after that is usually the time when most
people enroll in medicare excellent
danielle thanks for joining us today
your questions being answered are
already getting a lot more calls here at
650-1101
we'll be right back